this AI stuff is actually the end of
society I know people like to claim that
all sorts of advancements and
Innovations are the end of society this
one actually is because it impels people
to just Retreat into themselves for
everything so now we will Retreat into
our own fantasies for art it makes great
art so the art that I put up on my walls
I just type it into mid-journey or any
of them and get a beautiful piece of art
you'll be able to create these these
deep fakes of video and audio it's
obviously going to be applied to porn
people will have no reason to engage in
reality because one you won't have any
common referent to talk about you'll
just have I'll have my video of trump
and you'll have your video of trump and
we'll both have made them up we we all
have my fantasy that I'm living in be it
uh personal be it uh entertainment be it
be it sex be it anything and we'll all
just we'll all just be living in our
pods plugged into our own fantasies that
is the end of community